Speaker 1: It's quite remarkable that in a
short 48 hours, this entire Nicki Minaj swollen
testicle, Trinidad and Tobago story has gone
from something I didn't think I would cover
at all to something I ended up covering yesterday
because of how it suddenly pulled in.
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson to something
that today we're following up on, and it has
actually reached the health ministry of Trinidad
and Tobago.
So let's just go through the entire back story
on this.
The way that this all started is that a pop
star, Nicki Minaj, tweeted a couple of days
ago, quote, My cousin in Trinidad won't get
the vaccine because his friend got it and
became impotent.
His testicle testicles became swollen.
His friend was weeks away from getting married.
Now the girl called off the wedding.
It's kind of weird to be like, wow, that's
like if someone gets appendicitis, you call
off the wedding.
So just pray on it and make sure you're comfortable
with your decision and not be bullied.
And of course, so many people came forward
and said that's not actually a vaccine side
effect.
Just because something happened after the
vaccine, if it did, doesn't mean it was caused
by the vaccine.
My instinct was maybe maybe the testicular
swelling is an STD from an affair, and that's
why the wedding was canceled.
I even tweeted much to the delight of many
in my audience.
Back to Nikki.
Nikki, is it may be possible to swollen apple
bags were an STD from cheating, and that's
why the wedding was called off.
Tucker Carlson then got subsequently involved
and said, we want to interview this individual.
We want to talk to this individual who supposedly
had these swollen testicles.
This has now gone all the way up to the health
minister of Trinidad and Tobago, who explains
we had to wait a little bit before responding
because we needed to see was this reported
the population is low enough there that this
would be something they would have a record
of.
He says there is no such reported case.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 5: One of the reasons we could not
respond yesterday in real time to young age
is that we had to check and make sure that
what she was claiming was either true or false.
We did this and unfortunately, we wasted so
much time yesterday were running down this
false claim.
Speaker 1: This guy is disgusted, which I
love.
He should be.
Speaker 5: It is, as far as we know at this
point in time, there has been no such reported
either side effect or adverse event.
And what was said about this is that it wasted
our time yesterday trying to track down because
we take all these claims seriously.
Right.
Whether it's on social media or mainstream
media as we stand now, there is absolutely
no reported such side-effect or adverse event
of testicular split in Trinidad or ÉDITH.
The doctor has anywhere else none that we
know of anywhere else in the world.
Speaker 1: OK, so of course, if you're committed
to this story, you would say, well, a lot
of people don't report their side effects.
I had arm pain or I had a headache.
I never reported it.
And of course, if you want to be endlessly
skeptical, you can you can continue to be.
But that is the statement from the health
minister in Trinidad and Tobago.
So what's the real takeaway here?
The takeaway here is that we're working so
hard to get people vaccinated and to disseminate
truth and empiricism and and to make sure
that what's being said is backed up by data
and science.
And someone like Nicki Minaj, who's in a position
with so much prominence, nearly two hundred
million followers across social media, et
cetera, with just one tweet could theoretically
dissuade I don't know if I want to say tens
of thousands, like of the two hundred million
followers, how many are currently unvaccinated
who have access it set it right.
Maybe she's dissuading tens of thousands of
people from vaccination, maybe hundreds of
thousands.
Is it possible that it's in the millions?
I don't know.
But it can then take weeks to undo the skepticism
that's caused by just one statement like that.
And that's why this is so disturbing.
If this individual eventually comes forward,
Tucker Carlson goes down to Port of Spain
and interviews the guy the way he said he
wanted to do.
OK, we'll follow up on it.
But let's hope that this is the end of the
Nicki Minaj swollen testicle story.